return now to Washington and a big
decision from President Biden related to
the fight over the debt ceiling after
another meeting with Congressional
leaders he opted to cancel part of a
trip overseas as hopes rise that a deal
can be reached time is running out of
course with the administration and just
about everyone else saying that hitting
the debt ceiling on June 1st would be a
disaster a catastrophe for the American
economy which Zhang is at the White
House for us we should good morning to
you speaker McCarthy actually expressed
some optimism after that latest meeting
so what's happening now
and so did President Biden good morning
to you Tony and good morning to
everybody both sides say that
discussions have been productive but
they also agree that there is still a
lot of work to do and with the clock
ticking one of the biggest challenges
now is actually meeting that deadline to
avoid a default exactly why President
Biden changed his plans to buy more time
I'm cutting my trip short President
Biden's decision to ditch Australia in
Papua New Guinea so he can rush back to
Washington
underscores how little time is left to
reach a deal on the debt ceiling the U.S
could run out of money to pay its bills
as soon as June 1st 15 days away default
is not an option America pays his debts
pays his bills yesterday the president's
meeting with Congressional leaders did
not end with an agreement we're having a
wonderful time
everything's going well but they're
inching closer the structure of of how
we negotiate has improved so it now
gives you a better opportunity CBS News
has learned that house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy pushed for high-profile
negotiators to hammer out a deal the
president appointed three top West Wing
aides to get it done including the head
of his budget office Shalonda young
areas of compromise include permitting
changes for domestic energy projects and
clawing back about 30 billion dollars in
unspent federal covid relief money
Republicans want to add stricter work
requirements for recipients of Medicaid
and food stamps an idea that
progressives call a non-starter there
will be a huge backlash if we do
something like Institute work
requirements or cut spending more
broadly treasury secretary Janet Yellen
warned of the consequences of failing to
find compromise it could lead to a
downturn is severe here is the Great
Recession over 8 million Americans lose
their jobs and the value the stock
market is slashed by about 45 percent
wiping out years of retirement and other
household savings
President Biden said that even though he
is going overseas he plans to speak with
Congressional leaders by phone regularly
and that their staffs would meet here in
Washington Daily he plans to come back
to town on Sunday Nate
Ouija thank you